this is jennifer aniston she's doing the
auto complete interview
is that what it is
[Music]
and i'll be joining my name is jason
bateman see the way we're already auto
complaining
guys we're at a good clip right now
does jennifer aniston drink coffee i do
one cup in the morning
maybe a little espresso around three or
four
does jennifer manage to take vitamins i
mean oh my god is the pope catholic
there's a regiment guys this doesn't
happen just by accident
this she's pumped full of stuff filled
with b12s and c's like
all sorts of like d does jennifer
aniston really have brown eyes
what oh look at those blue things
well you she brings out the junket
contacts these are my junket contacts
yeah the blue the blue ones are not
cheap best is when i do brown and blue
okay where does jennifer stay when she's
in cabo oh tell the world
i'm gonna tell everybody does jennifer
aniston
watch days of our lives i don't watch
anything really is that dad's that's
dad's
he's still on it daddy's still on that
really since 1984.
how many years is that quick don't ask i
went to rudolph steiner
that's is that a bad school or something
no it's just slow
no i did not go to me neither i don't
have a high school diploma though
you don't no i was doing an interesting
story
i was doing teamwork too i knew it i
knew we were going to segue into a teen
wolf story
and uh during finals of my senior year
we were shooting teen wolf 2
and the workload was such that i
couldn't take two of my four finals so
they didn't give me my diploma and then
they hit me up for an alumni
contribution and i told them
[Laughter]
is jason bateman related to justine and
i get that all the time
no no no it's weird it's so weird
too is jason bateman left-handed
he sure is but i throw with my right you
do you're right with my left or throat i
don't
any more information about your right
and left hand okay next i think we know
where she's going with that guys
is jason bateman canadian how dare you
soon to be is jason bateman in mumford
inside oh yes you
are well just for one minute for one
being real cute in those outfits is
cheap jason bateman married to melissa
mccarthy yes
no he's not but when you but i would be
i'd love her to death is is jennifer
aniston related to barbra streisand
i'm not but in spirit we are i don't
know
because it's that bad is jennifer
aniston a vegan
are you no of course not i mean of
course you're garbage it's conflicting
it's jennifer and it's a buddhist just
smells like one
is jennifer anderson's hair real the
biggest surprise that happened on the
set was
how often your wig came off i know you
know just slips right up
the humidity in atlanta yeah it's the
heat it just
we found a good adhesive finally don't
don't do it don't do it
i just would be fun here we go ah this
is terrible
is this the is this the things that are
transferred like the google morbid
are you these are things that have been
googled they think that you're dead
because you live such a tasteful private
life no one thinks i'm dead because i'm
out there
running my mouth can't wait to google
this jason bateman
have a son i feel like i should have a
funny joke i know you don't
i don't none no two gorgeous girls two
gorgeous girls
love them both does jason bateman have
two different
another few jokes just popped to mind
color eyes
no oh but my eldest daughter but his
eldest daughter does
franny who does jason bateman look like
justine bateman even though we're not
related
um does jason bateman play in the hobbit
well it depends on what a hobbit is but
oh talk in the film play around in the
hobbit yeah you'd play you like to play
in your hobbies
no like do are people mistaking me for a
lot no no isn't he he's in the hobbit
right
isn't that geldaf gangando
ginga uh no i'm not in that love too
though
oh we got a whole stack of these what is
it you have an editor
do you guys need to reload or anything
no it's a digital that's why we're
never gonna okay what is
jennifer aniston's new movie about so
about an office christmas party
what is jennifer aniston wearing these
days sail around
okay gucci givenchy
no jeans i can't remember what is
jennifer aniston's father's name
i hope this stumps you that would be
uh no that'd be john aniston
and what is jennifer aniston's favorite
food
i'm gonna say carbonara
that's good that's kind of where i'm at
these days
so i know it's what i like to eat most
that you make i know
or that or your your taco tuesday what
is jennifer
aniston's natural hair color
there's a good way to find that what are
you saying that's a good way to find out
i know there's a good way to find it out
let's just look at the roots
i know what you're saying no no no no um
like um greatest brunette ever
oh there's more of this who did jason
bateman
marry her name is amanda anka love of my
life why did jason bateman kiss dustin
hoffman
we're at a laker game kiss cam hilarious
i love that man i'd kiss him again i
would too where did jason bateman grow
up
um mostly los angeles since i was seven
but before that
new york boston and salt lake city oh
not on a mission but learning how to ski
that's why you're so good he's such a
good skier what did jason bateman star
in as a child
what didn't jason bateman's starring is
this blonde question should be
little house on the prairie that was the
start
did jason batman die i'm dead with jen
aniston
this is doing terrible google rip and
tear
chat and giggle fast
[Laughter]
why do you want to know if we're dead
that's a good i'm that's
i'm curious about that well especially
since you've got good proof right now
that we're not
and i would also say the internet you
guys are doing great
keep it going keep going really seem to
be working out
bottomless pits it's growing and growing
yeah proud of you